s'il ya un secteur qui est fortement
ébranlée par la crise est bien le
secteur hôtelier avec nous ce soir pour
en parler christiane germain
coprésidente de germain hôtel bonsoir
madame germain l'ancien c'est fini dites
nous comment ça se passe chez vous on
présume que vous avez eu à prendre des
décisions difficiles dans les dernières
semaines
je ne cache pas que ce les dernières
semaines ont probablement été les
semaines les plus éprouvantes de ma vie
parce que bon on a dû faire après autour
de 1000 mises à pied temporaires mais
quand même pour faut le faire comme
entrepreneur ma grande satisfaction ça a
toujours été de de créer des emplois
alors faire l' inverse je dois vous
avouer que c'était là je pense que
c'était la seule chose
la seule chose qui s'offrait à nous mais
c'est la pire
la pire chose que j'ai que j'ai jamais
fait dans ma carrière j'ai trouvé ça
extrêmement difficile et je le trouve
encore prête ici
est ce que vous craignez de en fait
comment vous allez traverser tout cela
l'oeil à la subvention salariale qui est
proposée aussi par le gouvernement
fédéral comment comment vous voyez avec
les soutiens du gouvernement la suite
des choses
mais que tu es actuellement les soutiens
sont là son président sont les on les
reçoit bien mais je dois vous dire que
encore faut-il qu'on est qu'on ait des
revenus alors dans un hôtel on a
suspendu les opérations de 5 de nos
propriétés on en a gardé donc on en a 13
qui sont toujours en opération mais
c'est vraiment très très très minimal on
parle de taux d'occupation de 0 à 7 8%
alors donc on n'a pas besoin beaucoup on
n'a pas besoin de beaucoup de personnes
pour opérer à des niveaux aussi bas
alors les subventions oui mais encore
faut-il avoir de la clientèle est
actuellement et je ne crois pas que
je ne crois pas que l'hôtellerie va
venir même quand on va repartir j'ai
l'impression que ça va repartir
rapidement
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut même
oublié je vais jusque là la saison
touristique 2020 l'année 2020 oui
absolument absolument sans l'ombre d'un
homme absolument il y aura peut-être
j'ose espérer j'ose espérer que on vit
d'espoir par les temps qui courent alors
j'ose espérer que l'automne sera un
petit peu un petit peu occupé jeu je
crois sincèrement que le tourisme de
proximité va reprendre un peu les gens
vont avoir le goût d'aller de sortir un
peu sans s'éloigner trop loin alors j'ai
l'impression que le tourisme de
proximité va avoir une certaine les
jambes ont offert un peu mais alors à
luton
je pense que l'automne sera probablement
belhout a donc parce qu'en même temps on
a nous des événements on annule les
rassemblements jusqu'en juillet ça fait
même même pour la proximité ça va être
difficile c'est sûr que les gens vont se
déplacer mais on imagine que si rien à
voir ou à faire pratiquement avoir
certainement mais à faire il va avoir
moins de le faire sur le plan
touristique
non il va avant moi une chose à faire
mais compte tenu de ce que nous sommes
en train de vivre je pense que les gens
vont avoir le goût de deux ne serait-ce
que d'aller se promener peut-être un peu
à québec d'aller voir un peu ce qui se
passe même si les activités même si a
pas beaucoup d'événements je pense que
arriver à l'automne entre que je le
souhaite je pense que les gens
tranquillement et je parlais hier
justement un hôtelier à abidjan et puis
c'est tranquillement ce qui se passe les
gens ont été confinés très longtemps et
là ils vont pas loin mais il cherche
quand même à se déplacer un peu puis à
les voir aller voir ce qui se passe un
petit peu ailleurs
c'est certain que les rassemblements des
réunions les groupes d'affaires c'est
pas demain la veille que ça va revenir
mais le tourisme individuel pour
justement les
changer les idées un peu j'ai bon espoir
que tranquillement ça va se savoir
revenir comme vous êtes prononcer sur
les médias sociaux sur l'importance de
l'achat local c'est quoi votre message
de ce côté là mon message il est bien
simple on a toujours été d on a toujours
été dans le toujours été des gens qui
ont vraiment favorisé les achats locaux
parmi nos nos professionnels nos
fournisseurs ç'a toujours été
petite anecdote mon père a ouvert un
restaurant en 63 il avait fait faire les
meubles chez un artisan ébéniste à
plessisville et à ce jour cette semaine
cette même compagnie l'a fait nos
meubles mais toujours malgré on a
toujours malgré les opportunités qui se
sont présentées à nous à les faire des
meubles en chêne en asie peu importe on
est toujours resté ici à travailler avec
des artisans du québec et dans certains
codes d'autres régions au canada alors
ç'a toujours été pour nous très
important et c'est pour ça que je suis
très très fier puis je suis je suis pas
à 100% 150% le mouvement qui semble
vouloir s'étendre aujourd'hui parce que
je pense qu'il faut se prendre en main
puis plus on va on va être autonome
on va acheter local on va encourager les
gens de chez nous plus ça va être facile
de ce2 ce2 de repartir et de
tranquillement remonté la pente
voilà j'espère que les gens vont épouser
cette belle cause d'acheter local est ce
que madame germain vos hôtels vont
survivre à tout cela on se le souhaite
c'est ce pour quoi on travaille
actuellement je ne cache pas que c'est
une période extrêmement difficile
on se garde la tête au dessus de l'eau
et on travaille pour la survie de
l'entreprise
est ce que au québec en ce moment les
hôtesses ont désigné comme étant des
services essentiels pour les clientèles
avec des besoins en lien avec la santé
publique est ce que ça vous touche
bon effectivement il ya des gens pas on
n'est pas on héberge pas des des
patients les gens qui sont qui sont
malades mais il ya des gens
effectivement qui travaillent dans les
services la santé il ya des
gens qui ont besoin de répit qui sont
dans le service de la santé est
effectivement les hôtels servent de lieu
pour se reposer se distancer un peu du
bois des hôpitaux mais en ce qui nous
concerne c'est pas un volume extrêmement
important bon ben écoutez on vous
souhaite bonne chance
c'est aussi un secteur c'est le tourisme
l'hôtellerie qui est vraiment touché en
premier puis malheureusement qui s'en
sort souvent dernier de plein fouet de
l'est en effet bonne chance madame
germain merci pour cet entretien
merci beaucoup mais ce fut bien